You and I have been, uh, through a lot together,
I guess we could use this as an opportunity for us, uh,
collegial therapy about, uh,
the presidential campaign and then our time afterwards.
Uh, but you and I bonded over the fact that it's,
it seems like the media was more interested in presenting some
figment of their imagination
than the actual individuals that, that we were. Um,
and certainly I felt like that was true in your case where you had this breakout
debate performance on one of the first two debates and you were one of those
Google people for everyone, uh,
everyone was really excited about you and they saw what I'd seen already,
which is that you were speaking the truth and connecting with folks in a really
important way. And then it was almost like, uh,
like this strange, uh,
shark attack where it seemed like everywhere you looked there was some kind of
negative media treatment. Like it's like, Oh no, no,
like you can't be excited about this person. Uh, and that,
that was the way it seemed from my perspective.
But certainly from your perspective, I'm sure it was much more, uh, visceral.
Well, it didn't just seem that way. It was that way. Clearly someone said,
get that woman off the stage. That was very clear.
And I saw it in some of their eyes backstage after the debate,
when we were in the spin room, I saw some people whose eyes said, lady,
you're dead. You will not be coming back,
but I underestimated the viciousness, the,
the strategy, the obvious talking points. She's dangerous. She's crazy.
She's she's uh,
anti-science she's anti-vax she's you think I was well, whatever.
And so, yeah, it came, it was ubiquitously wasn't it?
That I had told eight patients not to take their medicine,
which was particularly ridiculous,
given my history with aid patients and the fact that at that time there was no
medicine. I mean, the most vile and vicious things actually. Um,
and I thought in terms of you,
it was particularly interesting because I thought that the, the massage,
Annie was very clear. You did things Andrew that I thought were adorable,
like when you put whipped cream in your volunteers mouth,
and when you crowd surfed and you know, all that, if I had done those things,
so yeah, it was, uh, quite something.
Well,
certainly you can't live in America and not know that gender plays an enormous
role, uh, in treatment of really anyone,
but my political and presidential candidates at a much higher level. Um,
and I agree with you that some of the things that happened on my campaign would
have seemed very, very different, uh, if, if it had come from another candidate.
And also you didn't have any previous political experience,
so why did they make that such a big deal in my case, but not in yours so.
Well, they mean they made it a big deal to buy the case too.
Not the same way. You know, it's not the same way you were.
No. Well, I mean, the,
the media treatment of the two of us was different for sure. Uh,
and like the,
the caricature as they painted were different and that it was painful for me
watching what people were writing about you,
given that you and I had connected. So like I knew you for months before these,
this, these debates occurred. Uh, and,
and if you speak to someone individually,
you can tell that they're thoughtful patriotic, uh,
sincere. Uh, and then when you see various things being written about them,
you're like, well, where the heck did that come from? And I agree with you,
like, I'd underestimated the, uh,
the capacity of the media to write a story that suited
their needs rather than something that they were actually interacting with in,
in real life.
Yeah. And the lack of journalistic ethics,
the using anonymous tweets as a source, a lie,
a false narrative is repeated,
and then they just repeated again and repeated again. Um,
the interesting thing,
and the sad thing for me was that when I actually spoke to audiences,
people knew who I was,
but what that smear did was convinced so many people that they didn't want to
come hear me. Um,
but I don't leave the experience. Uh,
just with those memories.
I leave the experience with very inspiring and motivating and,
um, encouraging and loving memories. Because as you know,
because you were there doing the same thing,
the people that we were talking to the voters were fantastic.
Now there's the voters. And then there's the political media industrial complex.
Uh, you fared better by the media, uh, political, uh,
machine than I did,
but we had the same experience of the voters and it was wonderful.
And, um, that, that gap between those two,
uh, I find tragic because what you represented, what I represented,
what Bernie represented in our own different ways was a different conversation
and no conversation, one that did not adhere to the same old,
same old formulations. And what I experienced as do you did too,
is that the people are ready for that. The problem is not with the decency,
the dignity, or even the regenerative interest of the American people. Um,
and that's where our democracy is broken. And I hope, uh,
as the months and years unfold,
that that rupture can be healed.
Wherever I went. People loved you. And I had the same experience that you did,
where when you have conversations with actual voters or
families, just trying to, to improve their lives,
it was essentially a completely different conversation than what was being had,
uh, in the media.
And that connection was for me profound.
I think you had one experience having that connection with people then,
because you've been, um,
a spiritual leader for so long. Did you watch the,
I watched both the DNC and the RNC.
I thought you were great by the way, I thought you were wonderful. Um, yeah,
so I watched all of the democratic and all of the Republican.
Me too. And, uh, you know, like it, it was,
it was a fascinating parallel universe.
Like I felt myself dropped into a really it, to some extent, both of them,
honestly. Um, but, uh, but I recognized more of one than the other, uh,
and the, and, uh, the RNC I joked, uh, that it,
it felt like, uh, like the movie Starship troopers to me,
I don't know if you remember that movie.
And I saw your tweet about it and I looked it up. Yeah. I.
It, a satire, but authoritarianism is what the movie was.
Well, I didn't think it was satire at all. It was the very real thing.
I thought that the Republican convention was evil genius.
I thought it was brilliant in its Maleficent,
maleficence, Maleficent. Yeah. It was malevolent in,
in a brilliant way. Um, I,
the way they took genuine moments,
genuinely human authenticity,
and they wrapped it around big lies. Uh,
I thought it was brilliant in a very evil way.
And also the thing that I felt was the saddest.
And as someone who wants Joe Biden to win very badly,
they prosecuted a case against Joe Biden.
Why didn't the democratic convention prosecute a case against Donald Trump,
if ever there was a prosecutable criminal in the white house, here it is.
They didn't prosecute a case. Kamala Harris is a famous prosecutor.
Why don't you prosecute a case? And the other thing is the Republican party,
even though the vast majority of it was lies, bragged about policies.
We did this most of the time, it was a lie. We're going to do that.
Most of the time, it's probably a lie, the democratic convention,
where was the policy?
So I hope that something was learned, uh,
by the strategists in the, uh, Biden campaign.
And I hope they come out swinging, uh, much harder, uh,
in the weeks that we have left.
What you say about the RNC.
It's true that they would take real human stories,
human sentiment, individuals,
and then they would wrap them in this other set of ideas or values or
propositions. Uh, and you would see it and the wild thing,
even for me where I'd be like, well, that part of it,
I appreciate and value and agree with,
but they've taken it someplace else that, you know,
I don't agree with or appreciate or value at all.
And that was like a repetitive theme, but you're right. It was very well done.
It was so they will take some story that is so touching
and so real that if you didn't know the facts,
if you didn't know the larger context, you think, wow, these people really care.
It was like a purse thief saying, look over there, look over there.
So they had you look over here so that you weren't looking over there,
where at what was really happening and that had to do with race.
It had to do with the economy it had to do with everything. Um,
they're playing a very tough game. Uh,
one of the things I said repeatedly on the campaign trail was that the only way
to beat outrageous lies is with some outrageous truth.
And I hope we're going to see some more hard hitting outrageous truths. Um,
over the next few weeks for the Democrats now on the campaign trail,
there were to be honest,
only three of us really laying down some outrageous jurors.
And that was you and me and Bernie and Tulsi to some extent.
So I hope a more radical level of
truth-telling, uh, will be adopted, uh, over, over the next few weeks.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.